all right so so let's back up for a
minute because your your specialty was
getting the thing there safely yes so
that the scientists could do their job
and so would I remember from Spirit and
Opportunity they preview that the
previous round of this they had like
airbags now so the thing comes down and
airbags deploy and it bounces until it
stops now you have curiosity because
those were the size of like microwave
ovens let's say yes okay
so curiosity is the size of a car yeah
and why not use airbags oh there are no
fibers known to humankind from which we
can make a fabric from which you can
make a bag that could handle the loads
of that car like Rover hitting the
surface of Mars okay so now actually do
you use what I'm told is called a sky
crane yes this sounds complicated what
what is that it's like a jetpack it's
like a jetpack the rover was sort of
wearing a jetpack and then about 25
meters from the Sun from the surface of
Mars the jetpack lowers the rover below
it and the to descend until the rover's
ok I think we have a long video of this
can you be like Bill yes I drew you got
the video let's check it out okay take
the talk us through it all right so we
hit the atmosphere going quite quickly
about 13,000 miles an hour that's fast
enough to burn up or melt the whole
spacecraft that would be uncool so we
wrap it in a special shell we actually
steer our way through the atmosphere
this is the first for this expedition
and that's where you see those rockets
going off we're actually maneuvering in
the atmosphere and then when we've
slowed down to about Oh a little less
than a thousand miles now we open up a
parachute in our case the world's
largest supersonic parachute we opened
about Mach 2 we get rid of the heat
shield that protected us from the from
atmospheric entry and then we let go and
we go on to rockets
now you can see a rover with its wheels
there's six wheels they're all sort of
tucked up and it's got this jet backpack
on top of it it's slowly descending into
the Gale Crater
we're looking at the ground with the
radar and then here we do the SkyTrain
maneuver we lower the rover below us
drop the wheels down both vehicles
continue to descend until Mars takes up
the weight of the rover we sense that
cut ourselves free and fly off to a safe
distance I
easy peasy right